est-ce qu'on découvrait n'attend que
finalement emmanuel macron il pas aussi
cool ce qu'on imaginait pendant cette
campagne présidentielle y découvre ça
alors maintenant seulement là pour le
coup je pense que ils ont ils ont craqué
là ils ont raté un en dessous de
politique en france il ya pour être
capable de faire c'est d'avoir fait ce
qu'a fait le président la république
actuel c'est-à-dire démissionné se
présenter faire croire à françois
hollande qui ne celui qui ne le ferait
pas tout en préparant ses dires essaiera
il faut avoir
il faut avoir une volonté de fer il faut
un président qu'on la connaît tous les
traits autoritaires il est autoritaire
une tradition qui est une tradition
française celle de la technocratie
française telle qu'elle est issu
notamment est incarnée par l'inspection
des finances dont il est issu et qui ne
pensent que l'état justifie l'exercice
de l'état effectivement justifier toutes
les duretés et pour le coup et c'est
ceux qui l'entourent lui ressemble ni
sonnerie là il a construit autour de lui
si on suit effectivement l'enquète de du
figaro magazine
on avait fait aussi une du même champ ce
qui est impressionnant c'est à quel
point il ya une cohérence et une de la
structure élyséenne du groupe qui est
extrêmement fermé et qui reproduit
l'attitude autoritaire j'ai à dire est
que si colère et aussi peut-être plus
autoritaire que son que son patron lui
même
le lyonnais qui en a fait l'expérience
malheureuse c'est le chef d'état major
des armées
par exemple